the reality isn't in technology
is that very very large tech companies
have a certain shelf life
and you can look at something like ibm
yep which was an amazing company from
literally the 1920s into the 1990s like
unbelievable amount of time right um and
and so i think there is real fear at
places like facebook um
that
you know they are very tied into a
certain thing and it's not unprecedented
for their time to come yeah um and so i
think what he did with the with the meta
change and all that is partly
a real recognition you know
that the time potentially is coming yeah
i mean look at aol and yahoo they were
just such huge
footprints in the industry and then aol
and yahoo essentially
you know yeah for all intents and
purposes don't exist to most consumers
as actual brands they still have a
billion users between them you know
going to their various sites but
so just to be clear jason when we say
that time is coming it's because the
blockchain yeah and
the way that we've taken
that
sort of intellectual property of the
blockchain and now started to apply it
to things like smart objects yeah is
allowing for a distributed internet to
appear
that's two-way
that doesn't require a platform to
authenticate so the reason these
platforms exploded between 2005 and now
is because the internet was essentially
a one-way thing like internet 1.0 was
you go fetch that web page but the
person giving you that webpage doesn't
really get anything in return for that
it wasn't a two-way system in the
platform ecosystem
you're no longer really fetching a web
page you're fetching a facebook post
and it's in the facebook ecosystem it is
two-way in the limited way that facebook
can make it two-way
and facebook can then be like taking a
toll on that whole two-way reality now
with the blockchain situation it can
become two-way and distributed
and then you kind of wonder well once
that happens who wants to be locked into
a platform right it's awesome yeah i
mean if all of the tweets in the world
or photos on instagram are just on a
blockchain somewhere
you just kind of like dip your bucket
into this
flowing data on some
network and you just take a big scoop of
you know here's a bunch of photos
about hawaii and
they're not on anybody's particular
server they're on all servers yeah well
what you're getting at i think jason is
like
this other big strategic challenge with
nfts in the blockchain which is if what
you say is true
then one of the big challenges is the
user experience
to kind of make sense of all this stuff
for everyday people and have it appear
in an easy digestible way it's different
than building the underlying
infrastructure of wallets
and the blockchain
like okay great that's
hard and it's being done
but now there's this other next layer of
hardness it's kind of like what apple
tried to solve with the personal
computer very similar which is how do
you take this underlying tech and make
it approachable for everyday people
that's what we're trying to do at ready
games that's what we're so interested in
is to to say look this is something
anyone
can use or do and that's why the phone
is such an important point of entry
right now because that is the most
casual
computing device that we have in our
hands
yeah and it's quite possibly going to
become the repository of your assets
like it's going to be your wallet it
already is to a certain extent i started
paying
you can sort of see it on your watch uh
or on your i don't know if you use apple
pay on your watch but at some point i
was like oh i have apple pay set up and
i have an apple credit card i said yes
to that and oh i can just
i started using an apple watch and i was
like oh when i'm in italy i can just
bang this against the little thing and
get my gelato like this is incredible i
don't have to take my wallet out and
that's that's what this nfts are going
to do right you're going to just have
these things stored on your wallet and
or on something
there's another really cool thing they
do
for kids which is totally overlooked
which is worth just unpacking for a
minute so yeah
i have two children you have a child
three three now sorry and
my oldest is 14 i think yours are even
younger than mine and so we all face the
same thing as parents which is
kids on social media yep yeah yeah they
want to go on tick tock they want to go
and end stuff no one who's and you're
like no way and i'm like no way
but why do we say no way and the answer
is because they have to be who they are
the financial model zuck put on all of
us was you have to be you so you have to
be you at the age of nine at the age of
12 right well that's super toxic so we
say to all those people don't do it the
facebook files that the wall street
journal released had really scary
information about how facebook knows how
bad this is for kids but the core of why
it's bad
is that it's the kids real identity
that's that internet 2.0 platform
reality so imagine for kids in internet
3
you can create any identity you want you
could look like anything if you're a boy
you can be a girl if you're a girl you
can be a boy you can be non-binary you
can change the tone of your voice you
can actually create a persona you can
create a whole social wrap
you can be a hamburger object yeah how
so you can start to participate in some
of the most fun aspects of digital
culture as a kid without getting
necessarily the
rejection that comes from literally like
how do you look at the age of 12 oh you
look ugly do you look like a supermodel
or not are you an adonis or not yeah so
you have a photo it's demented you have
like some photos you have some photoshop
team
taking your kids photos and right
airbrushing them before they put it
online like the kardashians do like
exactly so now in internet 3
all that stuff can happen
by building or forging your own identity
and then what's so cool is as you build
your assets and create your identity you
own them like you can actually own them
as the creator now they may not be worth
anything down the road or they could be
worth something but at the end of the
day if they can never be taken away from
you the way facebook could theoretically
take away your profile
before we get into the ad i want you to
go to linkedin.comtwist and post your
first job for free just do that right
now first job posting free linkedin.com
twist okay now on to the ad today many
small business owners are busier than
ever time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates takes
away from growing your business that's
why linkedin jobs has made it easier to
get the candidates worth interviewing
and you're going to get those candidates
faster and your first job posting is
free in just minutes you can post a job
on linkedin and reach the world's
largest professional network which is
now over
770 million people wow they're gonna hit
a billion soon you can use screening
questions to get your role in front of
only the most qualified people then you
can quickly filter and prioritize who
you'd like to interview and hire we love
linkedin jobs at launch and in 2021 we
hired a third producer a curriculum
designer and a couple more researchers
and we're still hiring when linkedin
jobs gets it done for us i love the
product so linkedin jobs helps find you
the right candidates worth interviewing
faster every week nearly 40 million job
seekers visit linkedin and you can post
your job for free at linkedin.com twist
that's linkedin.com twist to post your
first job for free terms and conditions
of course apply because they're giving
you something for free